yeah okay we'll start the next session
but first doggy is by Aaron support from
Stamford talking about methods for
computing stationary distribution thank
you very much for the introduction thank
you very much for organizing this
workshop so yeah today I'm going to be
talking about faster algorithms and new
iterative methods for computing the
stationary distribution this talk is
based on the following two papers which
are on archive and this talk is a
reflection of a sort of long-term
project we've had with a number of
wonderful researchers at MIT and Georgia
Tech and everything I'll be discussing
in this talk is the byproduct of this
rather concerted effort all of us have
made to try to get faster algorithms for
the problems I mentioned this talk
computing the stationary distribution
and simulating random walks and getting
new primitives for processing Markov
chains so everything I'll say in this
talk is joint work with michael cohen
jonathan Kellner John Peebles Richard
pang Adrian Vladdy and Anu prowl but
before I go on I just wanted to take a
moment to talk a little bit about
Michael Cohen Michael Cohen was a
graduate student at MIT and a fellow
here at the Institute
he was an amazing collaborator a huge
force on this project a rather big
influence in the theoretical computer
science community and pretty much the
account of anyone I've ever talked to a
rising star in the field as all of you
many of you know sadly he passed away in
the last two weeks and I don't think I
can do even begin to do justice what I
think the incredible impact he's had on
the community and like the amazing
impressive style with which he did
research and which you know how nice it
was to work with him but I didn't want
to at least take a moment to say that
everything I'm gonna say in this talk
Michael very much had his hands in it
and nothing I would want to say in this
talk I think would be quite what it is
if it wasn't for Michael's outstanding
contributions to this project and more
even the way I think about it the way
I'm going to describe everything is very
much the product of my interactions with
and from everyone I've talked to this is
not unique to me it was hard to have a
short conversation with him and not be
left with a changed view of whatever it
was you started with thinking of and I
think the fact that you know he was a
major contribution to at least three of
the talks this week it was rather
representative of his work and I think
you know in the years to come we're
still going to be for a long while I
think be seeing the ripple effects of
his outstanding work in style to
research
all right so without further due I guess
the main thing I'll be talking about in
the rest of this talk is a problem
you're all familiar with you've all seen
in some way shape and form the problem
is as follows we are going to assume for
the rest of the talk we have some large
directed graph will assume throughout
this talk that this graph is strongly
connected what we're gonna do is
consider probably one of the most
natural random processes you could
consider on this graph we'll consider
the standard natural random walk on this
graph so we'll consider the process
where we're at some vertex we pick an
outgoing edge from this vertex with
probability proportional to its weight
we go to the vertex at the edge points
two and we repeat pick an outgoing edge
proportional and wait and follow it and
repeat and the question we're gonna ask
in this talk is to can how fast can we
compute the distribution that this
process converges to if it converges to
anything in other words how fast can we
compute the stationary distribution it's
a little notation another way to see
this throughout the taco used the matrix
W to denote the random walk matrix
associated with the graph every column
of W is indexed by a vertex of the graph
and the column simply corresponds to the
distribution over vertices that result
from taking one step of the random walk
from that vertex so the goal and much of
the rest of the talk is to compute the
distribution over vertices s such that
if I pick a vertex from this
distribution and take one step of the
random walk I get back the distribution
or in other words to compute the vector
s such that if I look at the meat the
random walk matrix times s I get back s
so that's the main problem we're doing
consider throughout the talk all right
so why would you want to solve this
problem it's a rather fundamental
problem it's one of the first properties
of random walks and Markov chains you
might consider computing this more or
less corresponds to computing things
like personalized PageRank and moreover
computing this is related to computing a
lot of other natural properties of
random walks you might want to compute
things like computing commute times or
hitting times or escape probabilities
it's also shows up in some may be
slightly more surprising context so I
guess the yesterday there was a talk on
solving Markov decision processes and if
you want to solve a Markov decision
process so you have a number
States for every state there's some
action you could possibly take that will
give you some reward and randomly
transition to you to another state if
you then want to compute the best policy
or if you I guess let's say say you have
a particular policy so you know for
every state what actually you're going
to take if you want to compute the
long-term reward that you glean if you
take this policy look at the reward you
get do the transition and repeat if you
want to compute the average reward this
gives over time computing this is very
closely related to things like computing
the stationary distribution so when the
machinery will talk about this talk
we're also getting faster albums for
things like evaluating the policy of a
Markov decision process why am I talking
about this result in this workshop I
guess there are two major reasons I
thought it was worth talking about in
this workshop beyond maybe a personal
preference that there be at least like
one laplacian system solving talking in
the workshop and the reasons are as
follows first when I talk about as we'll
see later throughout this talk some of
the iterative the way will get faster
algorithms for solving a variety of
these problems will be by building some
what I think are rather interesting
iterative methods that I don't think
we've quite mapped to the broader family
of optimization methods we well-known so
they're rather I think non-standard
it've methods
tailored a bit to linear algebraic
structure of this problem I think
there's a chance maybe representative of
some broader sort of algorithmic methods
we're not having a handle on so if you
want a challenge problem to think of as
I go through the rest of the talk you
can think like maybe to what degree or
any of these things that we're doing
maybe representative of some new
iterative methods we're not using the
other reason I thought it was a good
thing to mention in this talk is that
you know the end result of a lot of this
will be some faster algorithms for
processing some things in random graphs
and I have some hope that these methods
could possibly be used to develop faster
algorithms for furture for their
problems down the pipeline so
combinatorial problems or further things
in solving random walks and as you might
get a sense from seeing how we go about
getting the results in this talk I think
any results that uses this thing is a
primitive to solve some of these sort of
combinatorial harder problems we'll
probably have to do something again a
little
standard or non-traditional in the
iterative methods in order to get that
work so I think there's some
non-standard emitter method questions
both underlying the results of this talk
and how you might use the machinery the
talk gives down the road all right
so computing the station industry is
fundamental well studied problem if may
be argued a little it's not not quite
trivial what I want to do though is
before going into what's the run times
we actually get for this I think I
wanted to say a little bit about why
personally I'm very excited about this
topic and about the work of this talk
the work of this talk so my personal
interest in computing the station
distribution or why I guess myself and a
lot of the rest of the group got excited
about this problem has to do with a
certain revolution that's been happening
in the area of algorithmic graph theory
over the last decade that many of you
are well familiar with many of you are
experts in so this is known as the
laplacian paradigm and if you haven't
heard this that refers to a relatively
natural I think straightforward idea and
the design of fast graph algorithms so
the plus in paradigm refers to the FOB
following says on the one hand there's a
class of combinatorial objects that we
want to understand better we want to get
faster algorithms for we could look at
the set of undirected graphs so these
are graphs with and vertices some M
edges and some non-negative edge weights
on the graph on the edges of the graph
on the other hand there's this broad
class of linear algebraic objects that
arise in a variety of contexts that we
might want to understand better as well
and these are laplacian matrices which
are simply symmetric matrices that have
non positive off diagonal entries and
have the property that every diagonal
entry is equal to the sum of the off
diagonal entry that is in the
corresponding row or column all right
now it might be immediately obvious it
doesn't take long to see if there's a
natural by action between these
combinatorial objects in these linear
algebraic objects clearly I can just
associate whether or not there's an edge
but we I and J in the undirected graph
with whether or not there is a negative
entry and entry i J of the matrix and I
can associate the weight of the graph
with the the weight of the edge in the
graph with the magnitude of the off
diagonal entry in the matrix so we have
this natural
objection between these two objects and
through this natural by ejection it's
been a long well studied area of
research you can try to go between
linear algebraic properties of the
matrix to get better understanding of
combinatorial properties of the graph
and this is through an area that's known
as a special graph theory but the
laplacian paradigm refers to is the fact
that a little over a decade ago there
was a breakthrough result of Spielman in
tang 2004 this is a widely inferential
very powerful result that showed
actually we can solve linear systems in
laplacian matrices in nearly linear time
so an incredibly well studied problem
the set of now faster algorithms we have
in improvements and consequences for it
or more than I can lists in this this
small part of the page but for that what
the laplacian paradigm refers to is
beyond the impressive research in
solving laplacian systems in nearly
linear time given the connections
between special graph theory between
laplacian matrices and undirected graphs
we can use the fact that we have this
new primitive for extracting linear
algebraic properties from these matrices
namely we can solve linear systems of
them to better extraction to toriel
properties of undirected graphs that's
what the laplacian paradigm refers to so
this has been an incredibly successful
algorithmic paradigm and for a long list
of problems you might consider the
fastest algorithms now use in some way
shape or form our ability to solve
laplacian systems in nearly linear time
so solving laplacian systems directly
corresponds to things like modeling
electric networks and stimulating
undirected random walks and computing
page recon undirected graphs there's a
number of numerical applications for
example madres talked earlier the week
on matrix scaling was using the ability
to solve laplacian systems sorry yeah
the ability to solve laplacian systems
and there's been a growing list of
combinatorial applications so things
like computing partitioning zuv
undirected graph solving maximum flow
and certain regimes approximately on
undirected graphs sampling random
spanning trees and it's been the rapidly
growing list of problems so this begs a
natural question what about directed
graphs
what about can what can we say through
this paradigm butter
get faster algorithms for solving
directed graphs and here there are some
very exciting results there have been
some real breakthroughs on our running
time for solving directed graphs but in
some sense the running time improvements
that have been gleaned are a bit more
mild and the running time improvements I
know from using laplacian system solvers
or the algorithmic machinery - that
underlies them to solve directed graph
problems essentially boiled down into
two main camps I can think of the first
has to do with you can view the ability
to solve laplacian systems as the
ability to simulate certain electric
resistance simulate networks of
resistors and compute where electric
current flows you can also view it as
the ability to compute minimum norm
projections onto the space of
Circulations of a graph when you have
that ladder primitive and it's not too
hard to see that if you can solve
laplacian systems you can implement
iterations of interior point methods for
solving a variety of craft problems you
can implement the iterates of these
interior point methods nearly linear
time so doing this and using a variety
of really clever sort of impressive
tricks to get fat to modify those
interior point methods there had been
faster algorithms for directed graph
problems like minimum cost flow directed
max flow insurers path with negative
edge wanks links and there's also been
some results on using the machinery that
underlie getting some of the fun serve
graph algorithms to get faster
algorithms for problems on directed
graphs when the directed graph is sort
of illyrian or undirected enough when
the cut metric on the directed graph
looks fairly similar to an undirected
graph and that's sort of the state of
thing these there so these essential
runtime improvements but they're you
know if the running times are still a
bit far from linear I think it's like m
to the ten sevens for maximum flow or
shortest path with negative edge lengths
it's not quite some of the full nearly
linear time algorithms we have for the
undirected case and this gap is for not
lack of trying or lack of creativity
there are some real barriers that come
up if you try to take any of the
laplacian system solving machinery and
use it to solve problems on directed
graphs
namely there's a lot of these results
for getting fast algorithms on
undirected graphs use our ability to
compress undirected graphs they're
sparse graphs that preserve their
distances they're sparse graphs
their cup cuts there's ways of
decomposing undirected graphs while
preserving their properties and it's not
too hard to show that a variety of these
things just do not exist for directed
graphs if you haven't saw it before the
example that sort of rules out a lot of
natural sort of compression things you
would try to do it's not very
complicated you simply take bipartite
graph a directed bipartite graph so you
put some n vertices on one side of the
graph with some n vertices on the other
side and start adding edges from one
side of the graph to the other all right
at all point in the same direction do
you stare at this for a little bit it
won't be hard to convince yourself that
if you can do things like preserve
whether the distance between vertices
then you can check whether or not an
edge exists in this bipartite graph or
if you can multiplicatively check the
size of a cut how many edges leave a set
of vertices you can also check whether
or not an edge exists and consequently
you need n squared bits in order to be
able to compress the directed graph and
there's an on-chip variety of natural
things you might do to try to get around
these counter examples but it rears its
head in some ugly ways for a lot of
these things all right so that's sort of
the issue with extending this machinery
and directed graphs and sort of getting
all the benefits of laplacian paradigm
for directed graph problems and I guess
that's what bring brought myself in our
researchers the other researchers in
this group to the problem of computing
the stationary distribution we're
looking for can we possibly get sort of
the same sort of wins from solving
undirected laplacian x' can we get the
same sort of nearly linear time
primitive for something undirected
graphs like maybe there is some nearly
linear time primitive that's just
missing from our toolkit and maybe if we
look for the write problem we can find
some sort of comparable robust direction
in special graph theory maybe we can
find maybe what we shouldn't be doing is
trying to use the undirected laplacian
system solvers and rather we should you
know find some new primitive better
tailor to directed structure where we
can solve this new problem in near in
linear time there were some really
intriguing or more broadly you can ask
like what is the right way for looking
for directed
graph structure that's similar to the
way in which we found undirected graph
structure when we solve undirected
laplacian systems there was some really
intriguing work of Fanshawe non-cheater
and equality for directed graphs and
some work on directed local partitioning
from Anderson Chung and Lang but not
still this like full sort of robust
nearly linear time algorithm for
extracting properties from from directed
graphs when you know the problem would
be very ill conditioned and poorly
behaved all right so if you want to go
and try to follow this program of you
know try to find this directed you know
comparably robust directed special graph
theory the first question you might ask
is well what's the right notion then
what's the right problem what's a good
notion of solving of directed laplacian
and the way I've rigged everything up
before there's a very natural thing you
might try if we started from saying
there's AB addiction between undirected
graphs and symmetric matrices that
corresponds just from associating off
diagonal entries with edges of the graph
you know we could just do the same exact
by ejection between directed graphs and
a symmetric matrices we could simply
drop the criterion and that our
undirected graph is undirected we could
drop the criterion that our laplacian
matrix is symmetric and what we'll do is
just a sine will just associate every
off diagonal entry of the laplacian with
whether or not there's an edge from idj
but not also from data all right this is
a very natural definition it's the first
thing you might try but the first
question you should ask when doing this
is is this actually meaningful is this
problem actually where a study like this
seems very mathematically nice but
that's not an argument that it's
actually useful for really extracting
structure from directed graphs however
with a little work it's not too hard to
show that if you can solve these
directed laplacian systems then the
running time you get for solving these
directed laplacian systems essentially
corresponds to the running time you need
for solving all the applications i
talked about in the beginning so if you
could solve directed laplacian systems
you could compute expected commute times
escape probabilities evaluate the policy
of an MDP and compute the stationary
distribution and so the main results I'm
actually going to talk about in this
talk is how to solve directed laplacian
systems
faster and therefore get faster
algorithms for computing the stationary
distribution and the slightly broader
set of problems I talked about in the
beginning all right yes missing
something so it's so gentle so you have
to do some transformation of like a
Markov chain transition probability to
turn into this laplacian form
so in a little bit later in the talk
we'll talk about the exact mapping from
directed laplacian to stationary
distribution and I think it'll become
really clear so yeah if you want to
compute the stationery but we'll talk
more directly about computing the
stationary distribution I guess for the
moment I'm saying take on faith there is
a homework assignment that there's a
mapping from directed laplacian to
stationary of Markov chains I'll do it
explicitly a little bit later in the
talk it's not clear let me know there's
the intuitive part of the question good
so the key insight in all of this is
sort of we'll eventually what's the
right class of directed laplacian it's a
target and there'll be only Rhian
laplacian x' and we'll get to it shortly
okay any other questions all right so
before I talk about what we actually did
for solving this problem let's just give
a quick summary of what the state of the
art was or what the fastest algorithms
were for solving each of these problems
compute the stationary distribution
solving directed laplacian systems and
all these other applications each of
these problems is incredibly well
studied there's a variety of interesting
work in theory and practice there's much
more that I could possibly cover and way
too many results for me to actually
enumerate but what I can say is as far
as I know all the previous results for
solving these problems essentially fell
into one of three categories all right
so first there's a variety of results
for solving these problems when you
assume some sort of good conditioning of
the problem you can compute the
stationary distribution when the random
walk mixes quickly and time polynomial
in the mixing time you can compute
personalized PageRank when the restart
probability is fairly high you get a
polynomial dependence on the restart
probability so a lot of these albums
there's some sort of measure of
complexity of the problem that you
depend on polynomially and with that
dependence you can get a variety of
interesting trader trade-offs and
algorithms that depend polynomial a on
it but may be fairly well on the
dimension or the size of the input
there's also a variety of results that
solve these problems approximately so
they only compute them up to they
compute them up to some polynomial
accuracy there's a variety of
interesting like samp there's some
sampling results and saying you can just
sting
between sort of like stationary large or
small or things like that there's
variety results on computing them to
polynomial accuracy and the other way
you can naturally solve all these
problems is just to use general linear
system solving machinery solving all of
these problems ultimately boil down to
solving a certain and by n linear system
and you could where the number of
nonzero entries in the matrix just is
the number of edges in the graph and you
could use off-the-shelf linear system
solving machinery to solve them used
fast matrix multiplication this would
give a running time of n to the Omega
where n is the number of vertices in the
graph or if you didn't think about
precision issues which i think is
something you should think about
conjugate gradient would give you a
running time of MN where again M is the
number of edges in the graph for the
number of non-zeros in the matrix and n
is the number of vertices main way to
remember this is the running times rolls
are all super quadratic quadratic or
larger if the graph is sparse okay so
the main result I'm going to tell you
about in the rest of our talk is how to
solve all these problems in almost
linear time the algorithm have a poly
logarithmic dependence on the condition
number so still run fairly quickly even
when random walks don't mix fit makes
quickly as long as they mix polynomial
equally they'll all have a poly
logarithmic dependence on the accuracy
so I'll be linearly convergent algorithm
so I have a logarithmic dependence on
the accuracy you're aiming for and
ultimately the algorithms will give will
use more than sort of general than your
system solving machinery will ultimately
use some graph structure to get faster
algorithms for solving these problems
these things that are relying on the
laplacian we've seen many talk this week
about taking advantage of graph
structure and somehow it is always there
in the in the theoretical computer
science community for whatever reason
it's always we have to go through SDV
linear system direct solvers yet that do
like quartile completion it's
approximate cortical yeah yeah and
actually usually I mean yeah so I think
that's a wonderful point I'm not trying
to argue I think that the theory we're
doing here is unlike anything that
happens in practice and that there's
unlike any practical analog for solving
these things quickly when I talk about
these previous results I'm saying only
the theoretical running times and not a
lot of the amazing
practical work that's happened one thing
that's really cool about this is that
applied people when you tell them oh we
can solve undirected Laplace in nearly
linear time they say yes so can we but
when you tell them we can solve directed
laplacian it's immediately in your time
they're like what we do GM rests for
that like conjugate gradient descent
yeah thank you
Thanks Thank You ver of the answer any
other questions
all right so how do we do this in a
quick in case you try to look up the
papers later we did in a few steps the
first step is we showed this was exactly
what you were asking about that in our
to solve all of these problems the first
we provided a reduction that showed it
actually suffice is to solve directed
laplacian in the case when the graph is
oil Irian and the case when the in
degree is equal to the out degree it's
not a direct reduction we provide an
iterative method that reduces solving an
arbitrary directed laplacian to solving
a sequence of illyrian laplacian systems
where the number of iterations you need
the overhead is just poly logarithmic
and the size of everything so that's the
first step and the first paper then what
we showed is that these are Leary and
laplacian you know when in degree equals
out degree you can actually solve we
showed first that you can solve them
slightly faster than if you then you
could if using just generic linear
system solving machinery so we got the
following complicated running time which
you should think is just a little bit
better than n squared when your graph is
sparse right this was a proof of concept
it showed that like illyrian laplacian
systems and through this reduction
directed laplacian systems did have some
non-trivial structure to exploit however
the algorithm we did use symmetric
laplacian systems so this was saying
like good you can do something about
understanding directed random walks but
sort of by bounding how well you can
approximate them by undirected random
walks on the right way so as a proof of
concept there was structure but not sort
of tailoring anything to the directed
structure of the graph alright so how to
do better in the second paper we showed
that you could get at this problem about
whether or not directed graphs
compressed so you can show at least for
the sake of preserving properties of
random walks things like commute times
yeah
things like commute times and certain
properties of random walks these you
could actually compress in a directed
graph so we proved that there are
directed special sparse sapphires
meaning there are sparse directed graphs
where if you want to solve a linear
system in a dense directed graph you can
actually it suffice as a soften in a
sparse one so you can preserve enough of
the structure of the graph and then we
showed that you given the ability to
specify directed graphs showing that
they do compress and some
reasonable way we then showed you could
go through the sort of a lot of the
amazing work that's happened in the past
on solving undirected laplacian systems
and then tailor it to this directive
setting to get an almost linear time
algorithm so we're not gonna do in the
rest of the talk I want to tell you
mainly about these the first and the
last results so I want to tell you how
to reduce solving or leering laplacian
sorry solving arbitrary directed
laplacian stew solving the illyrian the
laplacian s-- which is a sort of
interesting iterative method that i
alluded to in the beginning and the
wrestle talk i'll talk really briefly
about how you then actually solve a
learning laplacian so how you get
special sparsa fires and through that
build an iterative method for solving
them here than your time almost in your
time so that's the plan for the rest of
the talk any questions before I dive
into directed verses or illyrian
laplacian
alright alright so first question should
ask why do we actually want to reduce to
solving Valyrian laplacian systems the
short answer is working with directed
laplacian is in general or rather
degenerate so if all we have is a
directed laplacian meaning we have this
matrix where the off diagonals are non
positive and every diagonal entry equals
to the sum of the absolute value of the
off diagonal entries in the
corresponding column and for such
matrices even if the corresponding graph
is strongly connected there's a real
issue in solving them that we don't even
know their kernel so we can't really
characterize when they're even should be
a solution and if you're gonna try to
solve this system by sort of
approximating it by some other system
we're doing something recursive this is
sort of like the base sanity check you
should have that you at least understand
the kernel of the matrix and why don't
we understand the kernel of directed
laplacian this is getting to the
question you asked me earlier it's
getting the question asked me earlier
it's very related to the problems we
talked about in the beginning so a
directed laplacian we can always write
as the diagonal matrix corresponding to
the out degrees of the graph minus the
adjacency matrix of the graph transpose
ok that just gives the mapping of the
off diagonal entries in the diagonal
which means if you scale multiply the
laplacian by d inverse and d that means
we can write the directed laplacian is
the identity matrix minus the random
walk matrix this again which we talked
to on the beginning where every column
is a distribution over the vertices you
get from one step or the random walk
from my vertex and the dirt the posse is
just the identity minus the random walk
matrix scaled by the diagonal outdegree
matrix however as we discussed in the
beginning we know from prone fermius we
know that there's some unique vector
when when the graph is strongly
connected there's some unique vector s
the stationary distribution such that W
times s equals s and therefore this
means that if we look at d inverse times
s this is the current in the kernel of
the directed laplacian because we'll get
the d inverses cancel we'll have I minus
W times s just s minus s is 0 all right
so it says the kernel of it directed
laplacian is given by essentially the
stationary distribution right so if you
could characterize the kernel of a
directed laplacian you could character
is the stationary distribution of the
corresponding random walk matrix all
right
so even the problem just getting the
kernel of this matrix is the problem of
computing the stationery which is we
argued as roughly as hard as all the
other problems we said however Eliran
graphs are much nicer if the graph was
illyrian if the n degree was equal to
the out degree then it's not too hard to
see that just the degrees are the
stationary distribution and the all ones
vector then would be in the kernel of
the laplacian right so if the graph was
all Irian you know we know its kernel
very well it's just the old ones vector
ya know their weights are arbitrary not
negative when I say to every time I say
degree I mean weighted degree every
every day I mean the sum of the weights
leaving an edge yes
great great question but ya waited in
parentheses every time I say degree and
answers okay all right so this says y
Illyrian Quapaw students are possibly
nicer we least don't have this issue of
not knowing they're stationary
distribution however that doesn't say
why we can always hope to reduce to
solving oil aryan laplacian x' however
this isn't quite too too hard to see
we've just argued i can we have a
directed laplacian if we look at the
random walk matrix we argued that the
stationary distribution of this random
walk of HX times the degree is its
kernel and the claim is if you let the
matrix x denote the diagonal matrix
whose every entry is this vector in the
kernel of the directed laplacian it's
not too hard to see that if you just
simply multiply the director of the plus
UN by x what this means is you take
every vertex in your graph
and you scale the outgoing edges by this
vector by the coordinate for that vertex
the x ah then the resulting matrix is
oil Irian all right so I'll call this
vector X loyally reans scaling of the
laplacian so it says if you can compute
the stationary distribution you just
reweighed all the outgoing vertices and
you get an oil aryan graph seeing this
is not hard but just to introduce a bit
some notation we'll use in a second this
is connected to a certain algebraic
quick algebraic way of checking if
something is a directed Laplace
so we said it directed laplacian as
non-positive off diagonal entries and
that every diagonal entry was equal to
the sum of the off diagonal entries in
the corresponding column since the off
diagonal entries are all negative this
is the same as saying the all one's
vectors in the left kernel of the
directed laplacian ok so we say this
directed laplacian has non positive off
diagonal entries and tight column
diagonal dominance meaning again the
diagonal entries are the sum of the
absolute values of the off now a matrix
is our illyrian if and only if when I
look at the though all one's vectors in
the right kernel because that would give
that the out degree is also equal to the
sum of the incoming weight which I'll
say is saying that's tight row
diagonally dominance that every diagonal
entry is equal to sum of the absolute
values of the corresponding row so what
that means is if we take it directed
laplacian and we scale it by x clearly
I'm not changing it by the left kernel
I'm also clearly not changing the sign
of any entry and we chose X exactly so
that when I multiply it by the old ones
vector it's in the kernel so it's so
that means if we had the stationary
distribution we multiply it by the out
degrees and then scale their laplacian
accordingly would get an oilier in
laplacian all right so what this says is
if we knew the stationary distribution
of a directive laplacian we could simply
scale and use another valyrian laplacian
system solver to solve it all right so
this reduces everything to this new
problem of how do we actually compute
the stationary distribution assuming we
could solve valyrian laplacian systems
if we could do that we then be done
because we just use our illyrian
laplacian system to compute the
stationary scale it and then solve it
because solve the linear system with the
oléron laplacian system solver all right
so all right so how do we actually do
this so again our problem is we have
this directed laplacian and we want to
get this non-negative vector X so if we
look at L times X it's both row and
column diagonally dominant meaning every
which I'm going to denote at our CDD
meaning every row is large in the
absolute values of the corresponding row
and every column dial entry is larger
than the absolute values in the
corresponding column now the way we're
going to compute this is a rather
natural right
kind of natural iterative method that'll
try to improve the the proximity of our
matrix to being real column diagonally
dominant
so the rough idea of the iterative
method will do is just as follows we'll
start with some bad guess of the scaling
some bad best of how to scale every one
of the vertices in the hopes of making a
row column diagonally dominant it won't
work it won't be row column diagonally
dominant so we'll simply add a bunch of
stuff to diagonal to make it real column
diagonally dominant alright and then
what we'll do so when we add a bunch of
stuff the diagonal this will make some
excesses and some of the rows and some
of the columns like things will be won't
be tight there'll be a little larger
than this should be and we'll then
subtract something from the off diagonal
entries that's natural to turn the thing
into a laplacian okay and what we'll do
is we'll use the fact that this
laplacian we created came very simply
from a row column diagonally dominant
matrix and use that if you can solve a
leering laplacian you can solve row
column diagonally dominant matrices and
then you're for you can characterize the
kernel of this matrix that came directly
from it so we'll use that so we'll do is
then compute the stationary of this
laplacian using an or Larian solver use
this as the new scaling and iterate
hopefully showing that our matrix gets
closer and closer to being oil aryan
that's the rough idea the algorithm
looks like is the follows following we
start with we have some initial excess
scaling vector x this is our guess of
the oil the scaling that makes it all
aryan and this excess vector e that's
how much we have to add to the diagonal
to make it real calm diagonally dominant
so we'll maintain that eep Loess elf
this diagonal matrix plus our laplacian
scaled by x is row column diagonally
dominant will then do is turn this into
a laplacian and it's not too hard to see
that if you simply do this rank one
update of this row column diagonally
dominant matrix you get a laplacian this
matrix just has a little more in the
diagonal than it should so if you simply
subtract pick these two vectors to have
the appropriate row norms you can make
it so that the all ones vectors in the
left and the right kernel right so we
get this laplacian that's just a rank
one update of our own
diagonally dominant matrix will then do
is come try to compute the stationary
distribution of this laplacian alright
so there's a pretty easy reduction to
say that you can solve alright
saying that if you can solve linear
systems in no illyrian graphs there's a
standard reduction that was done also
for symmetric matrices so you can solve
the case when the diagonal where other
than having strict Angley dominance you
have two dangling comments like the
diagonals is larger than the absolute
values and the corresponding row or
column so what we'll use is that we can
solve laplacian systems in a plus l if
we could solve real column diagonally
dominant systems because these are just
a scaling away from a row column
diagonal dominant system well then use
that reduction I said to say we can
solve B plus L using an o'leary and
laplacian system and then what we'll use
is that the kernel since L prime is just
a rank one update of a system we can
solve turns out you can just directly
character any that you can show that a
plus L is actually invertible means you
can directly characterize the kernel
that results from doing this rank one
update so it's simply a single linear
system solve in a plus L that'll give
you the kernel of this new laplacian
alright so that's what we'll do we'll
solve one laplacian system to get the
new scaling to get the scaling of this
laplacian and we'll use that as our new
scaling and then what we'll do is we'll
update the XS vector accordingly to be
the smallest thing we can such that it's
real column diagonally dominant and will
repeat no if you stare at this for a
little bit it's not too hard to see that
this algorithm actually always makes
progress
if you really solve the linear system
exactly no matter sort of how you pick G
this algorithm will always decrease the
XS vector like the amount you had to add
to the diagonal to make it real column
diagonally dominant and the reason is
when we go from here to here we're
subtracting this rank one update this
was some mass on the off diagonals that
was possibly hurting real column
diagonally dominance so how much we
remove always gives us progress on the
XS so every iteration of this e is
monotonically decreasing right the
amount of excess vector so it's not
harder to
to figure out this algorithm be like
this is a natural way to try to make
progress but perhaps more surprising or
not clear is how much progress it makes
well you can show is the following if
you measure the original XS like how far
much you had to add to the diagonal to
make it row column diagonally done this
isn't too hard you can show that it's
not too large to begin with it's
something that depends only on dimension
but what you can show is in every single
iteration of this algorithm you actually
decrease this measure of XS by a
multiplicative constant so every single
iteration of this algorithm is actually
having the amount of excess the amount
you had to add to the diagonal to make
it real column diagonally dominant so
what that ultimately means is you just
need to do roughly like log n over
epsilon iterations of this algorithm and
you have a matrix that's very very close
to being real column diagonally dominant
so close you can just approximate it by
an earlier in the Faustian system and
solve so that's the algorithm so there's
a few good questions so there's a few
details hiding here you want to to you
have to talk about how precisely you
need to solve this to make the
iterations work out you have to talk
about the accuracy you actually need in
the linear system solves also makes the
analysis a little easier to make it
truly row column diagonally dominant
- like maintain a little bit of buffer
there and all that the log is hiding is
that buffer is hiding that buffer and I
guess there's another log hiding perhaps
from the precision with which she needs
to solve a passing system so it's just a
log in over this buffer that you're
maintaining good question any other
questions
all right yeah is there there's no
condition number no I there is I guess
in the you know possibly in the linear
system solver but in terms of the
convergence of this you say if I just
want to have something like alpha
multiplicatively row column diagonally
dominant
I need login over alpha iterations and
that and that and that works all right
so that's all I want to say with this
now I'm running a little short on time
so I might have to do the next part a
little quicker than I might like but I'd
be happy to chat about it more so we've
just shown how you can reduce solving
directed laplacian systems to solving
leering laplacian systems let's talk
about how to solve oil earing laplacian
systems in near linear time so for the
rest of the talk we're gonna solve the
same problem we want to solve ax equals
B where we're also assuming that the I
agonal entries are equal to the sum of
the absolute values in the corresponding
row so now L is associated with a
strongly connected oil Irian graph the
way we're going to solve this is the
standard technique for solving linear
systems what we'll want to do is compute
some matrix Z this fairly well
approximates the inverse of the
laplacian el and then run this simple
method known as precondition Richardson
to get a more and more precise answer so
all we'll do is we'll keep measuring
will maintain submitter and XK will look
at how close we are from LX k2 equal to
B transform it by Z and take a step in
that direction think of Z was exactly
the inverse of L this method would
converge in one iteration what we'll try
to do is compute Z that well
approximates the universe enough that
this converges fast so our goal is to
compute this pre-conditioner Z and
almost linear time such that we can
apply it in almost linear time and such
that we don't need too many iterations
of this method the way we'll actually
measure the quality Z is we'll simply
look at how close Z times L is to being
the identity matrix so how close is Z to
being the inverse of the laplacian L
well we'll end up doing the norm we'll
use in the analysis we'll end up being
the one associated with the undirected
graph so if I have an oily Rhian
laplacian so what it will think of our
Larian laplacian and think of the
natural
directed laplacian associated with it
where every forward edge we replaced
with a half an edge forward and half an
edge back so it's a natural undirected
graph that's associated with it and
we'll use the norm induced by that to
measure our progress now there's a real
issue in trying to construct such a
pre-conditioner Z and the real problem
in this is that sparse vacation or the
ability to approximate symmetric this is
the procedure that was used for solving
symmetric laplacian systems and there's
a real issue that the ability to specify
or approximate undirected graph by a
sparse undirected graph was rather
critical to the construction or pretty
much all preconditioners that we knew
before in some way shape or form and
those that didn't use something like
approximating distances but so there was
some sort of tight special approximation
that had to happen here however neither
of these things are known to exist for
directed graphs so this might seem kind
of daunting but you might also hope that
perhaps we can do better here because
we've assumed that our graph is illyrian
so maybe we can use or illyrian nests
together maybe for Lyrae graphs we can
get around some of these issues and
still construct this bar as a fire so
quick recap of undirected graphs parts
of occasion let's see what we would want
in the undirected case so in the non
directed case of specialists barsa fires
as simply as follows you have a
symmetrical posse in you you want an
approximate some a symmetrical plus nu
tilde that approximates you the measure
of approximation uses the standard
spectra one saying that they're
quadratic forms are multiplicatively
approximated up to 1 plus minus epsilon
for all x and we want you till de to be
sparse meaning the number of entries is
proportional to the quality of
approximation and the number of vertices
in the graph not the number of edges we
call you a special sparse sapphire if
both of these things hold huh I'm just
defining what it means for special yeah
just this is just a self-contained
definition yeah all right all right so
why do you want this in the symmetric
case it turns out if you have a special
Esparza fire for an in the symmetric
case then it's pseudo inverse the pices
as much a pre-conditioner if you could
apply it efficiently and why is it
possible
compute these sparse graphs that
approximate these sparse graphs that
approximate it basically has to do with
the fact that you can write a symmetric
laplacian as a sum of symmetric Laplace
ian's over the edges of the graph so
decomposes edgewise yeah I yeah I know
okay do propose over the edges of the
graph so you can subsample them and
approximate the matrix you try to do the
same thing for directed graphs the
simplest like oil Aryan sub graph the
simplest Aryan subplot laplacian of
laplacian is a cycle they might all be
long so the concentration equalities get
really messed up from samplings cycles
and we don't know the right measure of
approximation now I think I'm Way over
time so I'm going to do this that way
over oh how much do I have we do like
the one sentence version of the rest
gonna be happy to talk the rest of the
day all right so what did we show we
picked this complicated and measure of
approximation it generalizes the
directed measure of approximation it
implies a good pre-conditioner and some
bunch of other cool properties like
preserving commute times the way we
compute it is we went back to the like
the way sparsa fires were sir first
proven to exist by Spielman tang showed
you can adapt it to the directed case
big barrier to overcome where that was
tricking the analysis was something
about having to exactly preserve the
degrees or preserving all eeriness and
this was sort of the difficult thing in
the analysis that eventually made it
well work out the way you use it as we
essentially used a similar approach from
penguin Spielman in 2014 that there's a
cool recursion for writing the inverse
of a matrix by repeatedly squaring the
matrix we use that same recursion but
there was some issues to get around from
the fact that error grows a bit faster
in the setting that it does there so we
had to do some tricks to get around this
to make it work out that's how we solve
in almost linear time hiding a lot of
numerical precision issues a whole lot
of details on how to make these pieces
work also this would only give a two to
the root log Kappa dependence where
Kappas a condition numbers so there's
another trick you need to get it to log
1 over Epsilon
there's also a lot of tricks to get all
the reductions here they're problems to
work out I'm happy to talk about it more
but the upshot is directed graphs have
structure there's now a lot of cool
problems that are maybe
doors open on to use this machine to
solve and I hope you take this to go to
solve more problems I can't even think
about and maybe help us create this like
robust directed laplacian paradigm thank
you maybe we can take one quick question
oh good question good question so the
question was when in an MDP do you have
an oil aryan laplacian and i guess that
seems it's a good i haven't thought
about it i take it off on buddy guess my
first thought is it seems tricky to
still have like non-trivial action sets
that are always or illyrian because that
seems like a rather rough constraint but
i'm happy to talk about it more that's a
great great question but i guess the
point is that everything is really
reenactor scaling so it means if you
want to try to use these in an algorithm
you miss maybe have to reason about the
oil Ariens Geylang along the way sorry I
handed you the wrong cable Thanks
[Applause]
no it's okay